andrew yes want to ice skate
are you a competent ice skater
we're here at the rink at rockefeller
center bagel bagels
bagels bagels bagels
andrew today on worth it we're gonna try
three bagels at three drastically
different price points to find out which
one is the most worth it at its price
like making bagels you know that you
know what that shape is
it's a bagel shape circular food some of
the best foods bagel
bundt cake calamari let's gtf bagel
oh i get it because the o is a bagel
all right they're gone i'm alone
my name's scott spellman we're in utopia
bagels where we make
hand-rolled kettle-boiled bagels the
old-fashioned way and where is
that passion for baking starbucks oh
believe it or not when i was young i
actually worked in a bagel place
called boulevard bagels this place uh
is a good friend of mine anthony he owns
the place and like you guys together
there's no better partner you could have
and uh we're actually more of a trio hey
adam can't forget him
yeah so basically you know we have a
formula that's put into a mixer we also
use malt a lot of bagels made today are
used with brown sugar
it's placed on a rolling table it is
proofed
a little bit then he'll start rolling it
this guy right there
i call him the machine he's been wearing
davis 20 years
wow a lot of bagel places are machine
rolled there's not too many people that
continue to hand roll so before it's
placed in the fridge
it needs to be proofed and risen it's
something that's underrated
in in baking and if you speak to any
baker it's probably the key
then it's placed in the refrigeration
before it enters the next stage which is
the kettle
my ultimate thing is that feel on the
paddle
if you under kettle a bagel it'll come
out looking like a baseball if you over
kettle a bagel it'll come out too big so
after the kettle
we have poppy sesame all these flavors
and you're putting those flavors on
these boards
from there you put it in the oven and it
goes around one turn and you flip it
i always use the phrase round and brown
round and brown
all right let me get a drink
for the lactose slightly intolerant nah
for the lactose definitely going to kill
him someday
cheers oh it's so crispy
these nice creases right in the middle
right there
you can definitely tell it's been hand
made because there's
imperfections every bagel is a little
bit different see this right here adam
memory foam bagel gonna try it on its
own to begin with
super good doesn't even need a condiment
honestly best bagel i've ever had
perfect bagel a little cream cheese oh
cheese heaven the beauty of memory foam
is that when you sink into it it morphs
to you when i put this
bagel in my mouth the bread slowly fills
the chambers of my mouth chambers of my
mouth by stephen lim
it does have a delicious malty smell hey
we're going to kick it up a little bit
we're going to give you an everything
bagel we got cream cheese
tomato and of course our norwegian
atlantic
nova capers and red onion this
definitely is going to take it up a
notch
look at the height on that it's not mess
around
also such a beautiful array of colors
[Music]
oh god yeah is that incredible oh god i
could eat that every day
the rest of my life
[Music]
look at that bite
clean see you later see you later
utopia guess what i got to go
is an egg everything bagel
bagel fat in montreal everything bagels
are called
all dressed bagels really that's right
so do you call a plain bagel an all
naked bagel
now a very unique bagel it is the
jerusalem bagel
we're gonna eat it for dindin with some
cocktails
and dinner bagel let's do it
[Applause]
my name is enata dumoni we're here in
new york west village and this
is balboa nut restaurant we're going to
have today jerusalem bail how would you
describe the difference between that and
a classic new york
style bag we bake it only we don't boil
it it's a little bit more fluffy and
light and
airy inside if you travel in jerusalem
when you go around the old city or next
to the
western world you will see a lot of kids
like with a huge
tray on the shoulder all around
jerusalem it sometimes smells from this
bagel and this baked sesame it's like
absolutely divine so we basically make a
small snake
and then we twist it we brush it with
egg and then we
dip it in a bath of sesame and then we
bake it around 20 minutes 365 degrees
we serve it here with a great extra
virgin olive oil and zata
zatar what is that so wild herbs it will
grow next to jerusalem on the dry places
on the mountain
taste between oregano to time so are we
having those together or kind of wine
best way you rip up the bread and then
you put it first in the oil
and then all the that are just going to
stick with now this is very strange
i have a cocktail and a bagel
we got you knott's favorite drink ayala
in arabic
applying for let's go like hurry ups
[Music]
oh that is straight up juice
that's juicy moscow mule yeah moscow
meal if you guys don't know
is tequila lemon ginger but it's got
orange
is that it yeah oh man
okay i i don't know anything about
alcohol but it tastes like a moscow meal
there are so many sesame seeds on this
bagel and
there's anything i love more than
anything it's sesame seeds sesame oil
open sesame open that's right look at
that
oh man cheers cheers
[Music]
that's something else that's nice
this is a game changer a dry condiment
is not a thing you usually
come across uh-huh it's kind of like the
bottom of a bag of chips where you just
have like that flavored dust
but this is like a delicious organic
little pocket of flavor dust what do you
got the double dip should adam try it
um yeah
[Music]
dessert bagel it's not a bite of yours
do not shove that in my face
okay
ooh that's good bagel fox did you know
in 1963
the first bagel machine was invented
like the automated bagel machine
really and it was invented by a man who
was a math teacher by the name of daniel
thompson and he also invented the
folding ping pong table
wow yeah i guess once you start
inventing one thing
all the other inventions just kind of
like cascade out of your mind
and now we go to the one thousand dollar
gold bagel
which all the proceeds actually go to
charity that's what makes it worth it
yeah that's cool the bagel is found at a
hotel
the westin and the charity is the holy
apostle soup kitchen and we're gonna go
check that out a little bit later
[Music]
my name is frank tujog i'm the director
of services here at the western new york
at times square hi i'm craig reed
executive chef and today we'll be
tasting the thousand dollar bag i have a
passion for seasonal ingredients i
wanted to use the truffle growing up in
new york i wanted to use a bagel and
they just work so it's always been for
helping some sort of program it's always
been non-profit 100
of the money brought in for this bagel
is donated to holy apostles soup kitchen
which is the number one
food kitchen serving hungry new yorkers
in new york city
[Music]
i'm andrew st john i'm the interim
executive director i'm michael alley i'm
the director of operations
it's been going for 35 years it hasn't
missed the day in all those years it's
amazing even in 1990 the church burned
down
they served that day as well and we feed
up to a thousand people a day
every day about a thousand that's the
average year so basically the meal is a
nutritious meal that's made
from scratch we use no processed food
and anybody can come here
and eat here there's anybody open to all
this there's no means test
we are so glad to be able to talk to you
guys and see how
the proceeds are going to come and
directly impact all the positive
kitchens so thank you
we start off with a really nice new york
bagel then i take
mascarpone and cream cheese and i whip
that together so we smeared it onto the
bagel and then we had the truffle which
is the the main
important ingredient on it so we have
nice white truffles we shave those thin
then i
use goji berry jelly so i take riesling
wine and goji berries cook it together
cure it up a little bit thicken it up
and then make that into the jelly it
goes great with the truffle the pungent
of the truffle and the sweetness of the
jelly
then we have a little gold leaf for a
little bit of pizzazz it kind of just
heightens up the color a little bit
i have eaten more truffle in my life in
the last year because i'm worth it so
like people always ask me what does
truffle
smell like like it's hard to describe
well it's kind of like how
why do we enjoy eating spicy food if
it's hurting us
i think the best spicy food is right on
the edge of
delicious and pain and truffle is right
on the edge of delicious smelling and
quite frankly nasty smelling but it's
riding that line where
it's the best smell to me when i first
smell truffle
it smells bad initially but then it's
like
the more you smell it the better it gets
yeah we'll eat together right
okay bagel cheers cheers
[Music]
salt bagel that is really tasty
i would never guess that jelly and a
mushroomy thing
would taste really good together you
don't really encounter that that often
yeah
wow i i'm surprised the jelly just like
cancels out
a lot of the really weird funk pungent
like this dank
and it really brings out the nice
colorful
dank flavor of the truffle of all the
truffle things i've had this is actually
top two maybe i think this is a good
trouble food for people who actually
don't know if they like truffles or not
it's a good gateway
it's a truffle dumb
all right who's your worth at winner
andrew my worth at winner is
utopia bagels i can't find a fault in
their bagels
for me i so want to pick the jerusalem
bagel but i
it's this close but it goes to utopia
yeah utopia bagels is my worth of winner
i realized that i did not know what a
bagel was
i've grown up today i hit bagel puberty
okay and i learned what bagels are
hey adam what's your worth at winter
barb bowling adam picks barbara
yeah i get it i saw that a mile away
this is something i sorely miss
in los angeles i think people just don't
get it like there's too much sunshine
they don't
they don't crave the comfort of a warm
bready thing
because they don't have that deep
sadness that you need
you say hey nero is a sad city it's just
a theory oh
yes